Calculatoarele cuantice sunt menite să rezolve probleme care nu pot fi abordate
de calculatoarele clasice, lucruri
cum ar fi găsirea materialelor potrivite pentru a permite
captarea carbonului, pentru a duce cu adevărat
lupta împotriva schimbărilor climatice, pentru a crea
îngrășăminte mai eficiente care să
nu dăuneze pământului, dar să și continue
lanțul de aprovizionare cu alimente de care avem nevoie pentru a hrăni lumea
există și câteva întrebări fundamentale despre cum e alcătuit universul nostru
și cum se comportă materia la nivel atomic
și subatomic, lucruri pe care trebuie să le înțelegem
e frontiera următoare
să luăm un domeniu în care cercetarea e deja în curs
căutarea unor noi baterii
bateriile ne-au transformat viețile permițându-ne să purtăm cu noi
calculatoare și telefoane inteligente
dar mai e mult de făcut — bateriile sunt esențiale
pentru viitorul nostru energetic curat
fie că e vorba de alimentarea mașinilor electrice sau cu adevărat
de impulsionarea energiei regenerabile
avem nevoie de o chimie fundamental diferită
pentru a crea bateriile
de mâine; calculul cuantic
ne-ar permite să privim efectiv în interiorul bateriei
în timpul reacțiilor ei foarte complexe, pentru a ne permite să
ne gândim la materiale noi
și la structura bateriilor care vor fi necesare
pentru a alimenta generația următoare de dispozitive
cum ajungem acolo? construind cele mai avansate dispozitive cuantice din lume
și o platformă de dezvoltare
și punând-o la dispoziția lumii întregi
numai lucrând împreună acum
vom putea rezolva problemele cu care ne vom confrunta
împreună în viitor.